being a Samsung user is very exciting
when Samsung launches a brand new
flagship today we're talking about brand
new Samsung Note 10 and the note 10 plus
roll the intro what's going on guys my
name is David homage and welcome back to
the channel if you're new here we talk
about tech and gadgets that you might be
looking at buying right now in 2019
today we're talking about the all new
recently announced Samsung Galaxy Note
10 and the Samsung Galaxy Note n plus if
this is your first video about the
Samsung Note 10 or if this is your tenth
video about the no 10 there's a lot of
information out there that isn't covered
in the one space today my goal here is
to make sure to inform you guys of every
single thing about the note 10 that may
or may not change your mind about
pre-ordering this flagship device before
we dive right into it the Samsung Note
series is their premium powerhouse
models it's for anybody looking to get
the most out of their phone or spend a
little bit of time gaming on their phone
this isn't a device for everyday use and
it is reflected in the price point that
samsung has set out so samsung has come
out and said they're releasing two brand
new note 10 models the note 10 and the
note 10 plus in Australia right now you
can pre-order both of these models
starting from $14.99 for the Samsung
Note 10 and goes all the way up to
$19.99 for Samsung Note 10 plus in a 5 g
model now that's a lot of money for a
mobile phone if you aren't using it
everyday for something productive
something creative or for a business
purpose then chances are you probably
aren't going to be buying this phone but
if you have a love for tech like I do
then obviously you want to find out
everything about the latest and greatest
so when it comes down to the note series
everything we've learned in the past is
still true today however usually they
come out with only one note model and
that's the biggest the best and the most
powerful this time around for some
reason they come out with two different
models the 6.3 inch and the 6.8 inch
display now on paper you take a look at
the note 10 and you think hmm this is a
bit of an inferior phone when
compared to the no 10 plus it lacks
quite a few qualities that may be of
interest to you but if you're using a
note 10 just for the s-pen and you've
usually found it a little bit
uncomfortable and a little bit too big
well the 6.3 model the note 10 might
actually be perfect for you in this case
so unlike most sampling devices it
actually comes out in a spectrum of
different colors to suit your needs and
your desires for me I'm a pretty
standard guy I like my things to come in
black hence the time so I wouldn't be
choosing anything outside the norm so
the note 10 comes in a variety of five
different colors it comes in the aura
glow which I'm sure you guys have
already seen it reflect light and
creates such a unique little experience
in this almost silver kind of mirror
finish it comes in a black a standard
white and also a red and a pink so these
are a little bit different from your
usual whites and your blacks and right
now in Australia if you do jump online
well you can only buy your aura glow and
the black model I'm not sure if they're
going to announce the other colors or if
they're going to be specific to
different carriers which is more than
likely going to be the case but at the
moment it is raw glow and black it's
very similar with a note 10 plus and
with the exception that it doesn't come
in the pink in the red it comes in this
unique blue color as the fourth option a
couple of things to note if you're
already a Samsung user and it's quite
important because it means you're going
to have to retrain your brain to use
this phone is a simple fact that Samsung
has moved the power button from the
right hand side to the left hand side
where originally the little Bigsby
button used to be so now the big big
button is a multi-purpose button which
actually can be remapped to completely
take out a big speak which is great by
default it's set to a single tap to
unlock the phone and wake the phone any
longer than a single tap it
automatically activates big speed and by
holding down a button it does nothing by
default if you want to remap the button
then obviously you can have it as power
on and long press for complete power off
otherwise to shut down the phone it's no
longer available by pressing down the
Bigsby button or the home button you
actually have to swipe down from the top
the menu and powered down like that the
second feature to note which has kind of
been brushed under the carpet is the
simple fact that they've removed the
headphone jack now this is a huge deal
for Samsung because they haven't removed
the headphone jack in any flagship model
to date now this is also a cheeky little
upselling marketing tactic by Samsung it
means they're going to tribe up sell you
their Samsung Galaxy buds now a little
bit harder than they had done in the
past okay so let's talk a little bit
about the note tens features and then
we're going to talk about in the tens
plus advantages and additional features
so both phones by standard come with a
minimum of twenty five watt fast
charging capabilities the note 10 plus
however you can get a 45 watt
supercharger for an additional cost now
if you're unsure how much more power
this is from your current phone well the
Samsung S 9 and the s10 are using
something like a 15 to an 18 watt power
supply to get there fast charges even
though the battery is significantly
bigger on the note 10 it means you're
going to get a quicker charge with a
standard 25 watt charge and almost
having them out of time when you're
using the supercharger 45 watt charging
being the note series one of the key
features for this flagship is the s-pen
now the S Pen has gotten a complete new
upgrade again from the last year's model
it now comes in a unibody design the S
Pen has also come with some additional
updated features and some gesture
controls built into the unibody design
so now if you have your phone for
example set up on a tripod like I have
my camera here today you can actually
use it to record yourself or record
somebody else from a distance and just
use the s-pen like a magic wand really
to control the device from a distance so
if you want to switch between video mode
live video mode photo mode or anything
in the Samsung menu you can literally
just use the s-pen to swipe across left
and right and go between the menus you
can also flick it up to reverse the
camera and use the opposite camera that
you're using and flick it down then to
bring it back to the selfie mode so I
don't really know how much of
advantages is going to be everybody but
I can definitely see it as a
particularly use for some particular
people for example if you start your
YouTube channel and you don't have
enough to invest in a mirrorless camera
or a DSLR and a brand new flagship
smartphone but you need one to do the
job well the note 10 might be the
perfect device for you you could easily
have this triple camera design set up on
your tripod and get some incredible
content whilst also not having to worry
about anything while changing the
settings now sampling talked quite
heavily about the fact that they're
increasing the capabilities of video
mode so smart phones nowadays really
take amazing images and we're all very
aware of that fact but we know they
still are lacking a little bit in the
video department well Samsung has come
out blatantly and said that it is now
gone from a pro camera to a pro video as
well and this is exciting for somebody
like me especially the simple fact that
they announce super steady mode in the
Samsung Note 10 plus so the comparison
that they gave of the note 9 and the
note 10 plus is actually incredible to
watch they've used AI technology to
increase the stability and to actually
predict the different types of movements
that you might be making to create this
super steady mode now most action camera
companies actually bring this technology
into their cameras way way before this
smartphone was even announced whilst
other companies like Canon and Sony with
a DSLR and mirrorless cameras are still
actually lacking quite a little bit in
this department but that's again the
amount of image quality and the
megapixels you are getting out of a
proper DSLR or mirrorless versus your
smartphone having said that I personally
don't think it's going to be too long
before we can completely remove our
mirrorless cameras and just rely heavily
on our smart phones it might take a
little bit of time for the industry
especially as amateurs try to create
video content and photo content as a
business using a smart phone to adjust
but I think as a society we are going to
get there very quickly and our smart
phones are going to be even more power
and they are right now now a feature
that is unique to the Samsung Note 10
plus is live Bokke mode so if you've
used a new flagship phone by Samsung or
even by Apple you know that in the
settings when you're taking a photo you
can blurt out a whole background and
have a really nice bokeh what you
haven't been able to do in the past is
actually implement this feature into
live video mode using this in video mode
is usually specifically limited to very
expensive video equipment
now that professional-grade technology
has been brought down to consumer level
which is again very exciting news for
everybody that loves take as much as I
do now there is one feature in the note
10 plus that I would happily upgrade
whatever phone I was holding it in time
for so both phones come with a standard
12 megapixel camera the ultra wired 16
megapixel camera and the 12 megapixel
telephoto but the note 10 plus comes
with an additional depth sensing camera
so if you have no idea what a depth
sensing camera is it's the same
technology that they use with facial
recognition in unlocking your smart
phone today however they've gone ahead
advanced the technology to make it even
more useful to the consumer so if you
activate the depth sensing camera on the
no 10 plus you can actually orbit around
an object and the phone will try and
find all the different articulations and
understand what that object looks like
in its entirety example of this
technology is somebody on the
International Space Station could
potentially have one of these phones as
their key tools up there and they could
scan different wrenches different tools
3d print them on the space station and
never need a manufacturing plant or even
need somebody from the earth down below
now in all honesty this is a little bit
of a gimmicky feature and not everybody
we use it especially if you don't have a
3d printer or if you're doing animations
and video but it is an incredibly cool
feature to have and something that's
exciting to see in technology today now
I hope I've covered everything about the
brand new Samsung Note 10 and the no 10
plus if you guys looking at pre-ordering
drop a comment down below let me know
what color you're looking at
pre-ordering because I'll probably be
joy
sometimes so thanks very much for
watching the video guys if you haven't
subscribed already smash that subscribe
button
20:19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday